I didn't even make it through sharknado
I'm sorry I can't even I can't even
discuss that hi my name is Jill McAndrew
and I'm a shark dive tendon here at the
Long Island aquarium and I'm here to
review the accuracy of five classic
shark movies
all right jaws was well of course it's
the iconic shark movie did happen back
in 1975 so there was a lot of knowledge
that was not known but looking back that
had sharks ripping apart both usually
don't eat a big a boat for a shark most
great whites are large animals and in
certain areas of the world they do grow
quite large for this shark it was 30
feet 6,000 pounds that is just not an
average size for a great white shark I
would say the average size of a great
white would be anywhere between 14 and
16 feet as an adult far shark knowledge
goes it's really a one fin I watched
half of that movie and had to turn it
off sharks do not have to wait in an
ocean full of fish for one person to
come off of a rock that they may or may
not be on remember the shark is under
the water woman's on the rock shark is
not aware that the woman is on the rock
he's gonna go find food elsewhere zero
thing out of five
47 meters down was an interesting film
it was terrifying to know you were going
to suffocate to death you were gonna run
out of air
the need for the sharks in the water
just teeming with great whites hiding
skulking behind rocks it's too
ridiculous sharks are interested simply
in a meal but they're not going to be
going to expend tons of energy waiting
for somebody to come out of a cage just
for the excitement I would give it three
fins out of five we're going to pull
together a blue sea I enjoyed it because
of LL Cool J's he ate my burger teen I
thought that was funny
but the idea that you could take mako
sharks and put a chemical in them to
make them you mungus and make them wild
vicious killers is it's too ridiculous
animals programmed for 400 million years
and we're just going to take him put him
in the lab and put a drug in his brain
and he's gonna change his whole
personality it's too ridiculous I'll
give it one fin for LL Cool J Hollywood
is not going for accuracy they're going
for horror if I had one message respect
them as part of nature one that keeps
the balance of the ocean in check and to
remember that we are far more their
predator than they are ours
[Music]
hey unsub is on a new channel and now
you're part subscribe here that was my
part